nous sommes devant le stylisme et ses
khatib bonjour cathy c'est cathy qui est
en charge de nous habiller c'est elle
qui a choisi ma cravate journée celle
qui est qui et qui a choisi ce bout
cette baisse pour vous voilà alors j'ai
des questions gays alors qu'ati quel est
le chroniqueur le plus difficile dhabi
alors le plus difficile à oublier
pourquoi et pourquoi et pourquoi alors
mais regardez celle à s'attaquer qu'aux
salles à tout ça c'est à nicolas
pernikoff c'est pas vrai mais oui parce
qu'en fait il a beaucoup de mal à
trouver ses chemises mais il veut
toujours que noah mais en même temps
jamais s'il sera vendu seul daltoniens
mais c'est tout les mêmes en fait c'est
à peu près tout les mêmes
il ya des longueurs de brin différent
c'est après c'est très compliqué
d'évoquer le chroniqueur parce qu'il ya
un problème concret sur un plateau oui
il fait chaud pendant que cyril neveu
jamais qu'on mette la clef venant jamais
malade donc aux dockers ont su quartier
d'evry qui sut le plus mal c'est
décidément et ses démons quelques
chroniqueurs quelques chroniqueurs ne
connais toujours pas votre prénom
alors non je ne dirais pas nicolas cas
très bien très bien
presque plus mais nous alors peut-être
d'ici là bas ça se voit
quelques chroniqueurs passent le plus de
temps à draguer s'habiller personne
m'aidera souveraine ont vraiment tout le
monde est très correcte et très gentil
non vraiment il ya en tout c'est une
équipe qui n'est jamais content de sa
tenue qui nicolas pierre louis nicolaï
nicolas vraiment fois apparemment nous
sommes les [ __ ] d'été lui demander
qu'elle trouvait le plus sympa alors
c'est qui le convecteur le plus sympa
c'est moi le plus sympa à peine et la
bac d'abord
babar et si moi je te sens-tu rien dire
non plus sympa moi j'aime beaucoup ma is
a way
j'aime beaucoup montiel j'aime beaucoup
géraldine et j'aime beaucoup je t'aime
beaucoup de tanks et ses travaux à votre
avis
allez on va avancer à les amis 1,6 et si
j'avais jamais quand même qu'ils sont
très importants entre nous parce que la
personne ne regarde non bonjour monsieur
hiver comment vous trouvez le cycle de
cyril hanouna bien très bien je trouve
change en bien très bien chaud
oui c'est vrai mais comme son neveu
alors les propos de madame sa styliste
fait un très bon travail et il est
toujours différent moi j'aime beaucoup
très bien mais c'est quoi la